il se veut le patient zéro ou tout au
moins des premiers à se porter
volontaires en russe une armée de
caméras l'attendait dans cette
polyclinique de moscou où il sera
vacciné sous peu contre lakovic 19
c'est un tout petit pas pour l'homme
mais un grand pas pour l'humanité lance
dimitri big ben ayed et les références à
la conquête de l'espace ne s'arrête pas
là le vaccin heureux ça a été baptisé le
spoutnik 5 comme le premier satellite
soviétique
c'est une grande fierté d'être aux
premières loges d'une telle percée
scientifique dit la directrice de la
polyclinique qui vient tout juste de
recevoir les doses de ce que la russie
prête à être le premier antidote au
virus qui a bouleversé la planète
[Applaudissements]
développé à la vitesse grand v dans ses
laboratoires du prestigieux institut
gamaleya de moscou le vaccin spoutnik à
d'abord été testé sur des souris et des
singes puis administrés à titre d'essai
sur des jeunes militaires en santé ya
quelques semaines seulement
et voilà qu'un mois plus tard à peine
l'appel aux volontaires est lancé en
guise de phase 3 de large
appelez-moi courageux si vous voulez
dimitri même si c'est dangereux c'est
tout un honneur d'être un pionnier oui
deux classes 3 elena qui prouve à une
enseigne ans dit qu'elle se portera
volontaire sans hésiter les enseignants
et les travailleurs de la santé ont
d'ailleurs été les premiers invités à se
faire vacciner en masse sans prospectus
it's been bicross de directeur par
exemple une chute d'août
l'avocat iouri varlamov dirige un
syndicat d'enseignant à moscou il craint
surtout les effets secondaires d'un
vaccin qui est encore loin d'avoir fait
ses preuves de mission que son syndicat
a lancé exige la garantie que ses
membres auront le droit de le refuser
car les recherches ne seront pas
concluant
quoique les résultats préliminaires
publiés cette semaine dans la revue de
l'année sept confirment que le vaccin
russe administré en deux étapes
déclenche une réponse immunitaire
mais cette même étude prévient qu'il est
encore beaucoup trop tôt pour dire qu'il
est sécuritaire et efficace
n'empêche les carnets de commandes pour
le premier vaccin le spoutnik sont déjà
plaints au moins 48 nous ont manifesté
leur intérêt dit kirill dmitriev dont le
fonds d'investissement à financer la
recherche
et ce au grand bonheur du président
vladimir poutine dont la fille a servi
de cobaye
tout comme son ministre de la défense
just for good enough estime du show date
avec un tact à reprofiler chaîne dimitri
lui sera dans deux mois que presse il
est immunisé contre lacko vide mais il
faudra en réalité des milliers d'autres
comme lui pour que la russie puisse
vraiment crier victoire ici tamar alter
escaut radio-canada mois